I love your lingerie line that's a very  good Valentine's Day gift I think right  the Heidi Klum intimates I would say so  if it's a lingerie definitely I mean  it's on Sunday you know I definitely  would wear something saucy something  sexy why not Rico is a lucky man what  are your valentine's day plans my plans  I don't have a lot of plans probably  stay in bed all day oh that's really the  best plan not doing too much if you know  what I mean does he have a favorite  ensemble of the Heidi Klum intimates  veto I don't want it I don't want to say  but I don't want to say I like that it's  gonna be leavin it all comes up I guess  I don't blame him for a hot couple